these 10 people represent everyone in
America this person on the left she
represents the poorest 10% of Americans
and on the right he is the very richest
10% so let's ask this group a simple
question what percentage of your income
gets taxed most Americans pay multiple
income taxes to the federal government
and state governments and local
governments but a recent analysis by two
economists added up all the income taxes
and when you do that the data shows that
poor people pay a very small part of
their income to the government and rich
people pay more this concept of taxing
the poor at a lower rate and taxing the
rich more this is called progressive
taxation
it's how taxes work in most countries
but it's also by some critical question
whether these people are getting away
without paying their fair share the
middle class and the poor that pay if
anything a lot less why is it that 45%
of the population of this country is not
contributing back to the rest but now
let's add one more guy to this group of
10 this guy he represents the 400
richest Americans billionaires
billionaires don't make most of their
money through typical income so their
income actually gets taxed at lower
rates than these less rich people now
you might be thinking don't billionaires
pay taxes in other ways and the answer
is yes this is just the income taxes and
there are lots of other kinds of taxes
in America and this analysis where this
data came from it looked at all those
taxes and it shows that when we add them
all up there actually is someone in this
group who might not be paying their fair
share let's go back to our first chart
with these eleven people remember this
is just the income tax what happens when
we add in all the other taxes well let's
look at another kind of tax corporate
and property taxes these are the taxes
we pay on things we own usually
businesses and property and the money we
make on them usually rich people own
more things so these corporate and
property taxes hit them the hardest
rich people also tend to be from rich
families and when they inherit a lot of
money the government taxes them this is
called an estate tax put these taxes
together and it's clear that they play
some much heavier burden on the rich
including billionaires add these back on
to the income taxes and it looks like
the rich really do pay way more than the
poor but now let's talk about another
tax
this one's buried in your pay stub look
closely and you'll see something called
a Medicare tax and a Social Security tax
sometimes pay stubs call them FICA
anyway combined these are called payroll
taxes Medicare and Social Security are
two really important programs they
provide healthcare and a modest income
for when we get old and retire but
they're also expensive which is why we
have these payroll taxes separate from
the income tax to pay for them so on
your paycheck you'll notice that your
tax seven point six five percent in
payroll taxes and your company is
supposed to pay another seven point six
five percent on your behalf but
economists I found that in practice the
way companies pay their part of the
payroll tax is by just paying workers
less so in reality many workers pay
nearly the full 15.3% toward this tax
and everyone is on the hook for the same
percentage of the wealthy once someone
earns more than about a hundred thirty
thousand dollars a year the money they
make beyond that is in subject to the
Social Security tax it's capped that
means the rich pay a really small
portion of their income toward payroll
taxes and poor people in the middle
class pay way more add payroll taxes
onto this chart and it starts to flatten
out
the last type of taxes we're going to
look at are the taxes we pay when we buy
stuff for example let's say you're
looking to buy a t-shirt when you
checkout you pay a sales tax which is a
percentage of its cost and sales taxes
apply to most things furniture toilet
paper
laundry detergent for some items like
beer and gasoline there are additional
taxes that get incorporated into the
price tag before you even get to the
store these are called consumption taxes
and we all pay the same rate on the
things we buy regardless of our rich we
are now you might think that since rich
people usually buy more things and more
expensive things they pay a larger
percentage of their income toward these
taxes but relative to how much money
they have the stuff they buy and the
taxes they pay on that stuff take up a
relatively small portion of their income
meanwhile everyone even people with
almost no money needs to buy certain
basic things to survive and for poor
people those basic things and the Texas
that come with them cost them almost
everything they earn so if we chart how
much of their income each of these
people pays in consumption taxes you can
see that poor people pay a much larger
portion when we put these taxes together
suddenly we see a big change
the chart shows us that this line from
before it's a lie that America's tax
system as a whole isn't very progressive
instead it's mostly flat poor people pay
about the same portion of their income
in taxes as rich people and this guy
this billionaire is paying a smaller
portion than everyone else even the
poorest if you just look at certain
types of taxes it's natural to assume
that rich people pay a bigger tax burden
in the US and that poor people aren't
exactly paying their fair share but a
more complete look at the bigger picture
challenges that and it suggests that if
we're looking for a group that isn't
paying their fair share we might be
looking on the wrong end
[Music]
you
[Music]